hey there folks Chris waters here
welcome back to the gamespot stage at e3
2014 we've been seeing a bunch of Vita
games on the stage now and from the
moody atmosphere of Murasaki baby to the
four player co-op giant takedown action
of freedom wars it's run the gamut and
that gamut is about to get longer with
big fest on this couch joining me is Lee
from Sony Europe here to talk about a
music themed game for the Vita but it's
not really like any music themed game
I've we've heard of before Lee no I mean
the thing that's really saw unique about
bit faster plus I'll give you the
background as this idea this notion that
real artists can get inside the game so
i'll give you a soft quick background of
the game big fast you create build and
manage the ultimate music festival and
you start off in a small field with 20
guests a slow clapping all the way up to
global multi-day mega festivals with
international headline acts the whole
Jabbar and yeah the premises that you
start out with in a field with Dave as
you're like roadie I'd have a roadie if
your throne of music but absolutely and
they will take you through like how you
let stabil your first of all so from the
very beginning your thoughts basic
navigation and then in you're giving
your first post off and the way that the
game presents levels with is actually
via posters so different posters have
different objectives we have two types
of poster one of them is like used for
just playing the kind of music that you
want then we also have special posters
that the spoke and they're like story
mode so we can kind of do whatever we
want within those and as a free to play
game obviously the world's our oyster as
far as what we do in those in those
levels so in terms of the player
experience sort of hopping in you are
basic there's basically sort of a
there's a constructing a building of
planning out nature that's the sort of
core to this game you want to create the
fairground sort of do you manage like
flow like choose where to put the food
where to put the the camping areas all
that stuff absolutely so yeah initially
when you first starts out
you don't have any cash so you have very
limited cash and as people come in the
door they start complaining almost
immediately the thing you know they're
hungry or and then we'll need to put
some hotdogs stalls down maybe and then
you know people are upset because the
music isn't there so it's very immediate
I mean you start placing down objects
almost instantly and yeah as soon as the
sorts of visitors starting to show up so
here's one now and we tough on them and
they'll say hey look this is getting
pretty busy where the band's so this is
the band's right this is the music menu
this is where it's the really strong
aspect of the game everyone wants to get
their sort of tracks in the game that's
what we want we want to allow people to
put their own music in the game and so
that bad I mean that those are real
musicians in a real bad this is the
really important thing to get across
this is actual bands that want to get a
break and you know this is a perfect
vehicle it's like hey we could actually
get our music out in the global you know
community and they can hear it people
can play the game and actually play the
music within the game of alton rate so
yes a massive strong aspects of the game
very cool and now this is you know the
way sort of music has come into games
like this has predominantly been i guess
sort of you know i'm at matter of you
guys sort of the developer reaching out
and saying you know we want these bent
songs in our games we want sort of
recognizable stuff that people know to
come into our game but you guys are sort
of twisting that around because these
are bands that you know aren't signed
other people don't necessarily know
about them and you're try it's like a
vehicle for exposure for them absolutely
i mean you know initially when we
started out it was like we'd really like
to have commercial music man think it's
a free-to-play game so so that some of
that stuff's off limits just budgetary
wise you know and so we started looking
at me maybe we could build a game where
he's actually about the people that got
about real bands so as you build a
festival when you put your stage down
you're actually putting relax on and you
start to care more about the game
because these are real
people and the interesting thing is that
when you actually play these tracks this
is what is going on here big trail mix
got horribly rocks happen berries this
is and we also have this aspect the
social aspect where you go and visit
your friends and you can build your own
festival and visit your friends and you
can have the competitive or cooperative
so in this instance somebody just blew
up the video screen and electrocuted a
bunch of their festival goers right and
but you know that sinister s kind of
been a bit mean but you don't have to go
that way you could if you want to be a
nice guy you can do that too and oh yeah
we just want to give you the all of
these different options and make it so
you know a little bit more of a twist on
a social game all right so in this
example now at this point we've now
unlocked the music chart so as I said
earlier when you actually played it the
bands on the stage you're actually
breitung them so if I say that this band
is going in my headline slot within the
poster aha you're actually saying these
are a really good band and that actually
that those scores are aggregated and it
creates an actual music chart so we're
actually reflecting the community's
likes of the music and if the tracks
aren't played they'll fall out of the
chart and tracks that are gray will go
to the top so they are yet genuinely get
in real exposure and is there you know
sort of does that translate you know I'm
playing big fest at their game their
songs that I like their songs that I
discover you said here there's a mode
where you can just listen to the music
from the game that's right is there then
the link to like I want to download this
song to my you know it's a my mp3 player
to my phone to my this absolutely no I
mean the deal that we have with jamendo
you can see the log over there I'm
allows us yes access to that to the the
catalog so you know we have like access
to 2200 tracks across Europe and yes you
can pull down those tracks locally if
you want to play them locally and it's
gonna be really excited
very cool uh so you know with when
you're creating a music festival you are
you a sort of these challenges you're
talking about the posters is it like
throw the most thrashing death metal
music festival possible or get a certain
amount of fans to come to your music
festival we have been we have various
different sort of tasks within the
festival one might be like a bunch of
bikers coming dead brush and you need to
add victim or you know we have a bunch
of crazy clowns like the clown posse
will come in and you need to address
those there's lots of different specific
tasks guys climbing the fence fights
mosh pits and all of the stuff you would
expect to see in a really crazy busy
festival all of the stuff well maybe not
some of it right we're a 12 need to be a
little bit careful but yeah you get the
idea you know we want to kind of touch
upon the culture festival goers sure
don't be too edgy without going full
Woodstock maybe precisely uh so you know
I loved this Big Dave roadie icon violin
its like the Big Davies tours like the
kind I don't need you know lemme of
motörhead yeah in the seventies you've
got that whole Dario the cowboy hat the
gruff caught me guy yeah are you know
this is on the beat are using touch
screens to sort of control this proper
use of these dicks as well now it's
touchscreen and stick so we use a jewel
analogs for the camera so you plan
around you do full rotation of the
festival but also touchscreen so all of
these side panels you have the left is a
social menu to the right is your music
menu at the bottom is the create panel
where you fill your different objects
within the scene now we've sort of
talked about the social stuff a little
bit d you know pranking a friends
festival or helping them out somehow I
is that sort of the extent of the
sharing or can you like like I believe
people you can go attend someone else's
festival that they've you know it sort
of sit through their music selection
that's been curated for you right that's
right i mean yeah you're effectively
building a festival but with using the
music that you like you're also dressing
nihilistic we the festival using you
know your own art so if you're into
reggae you might have a really Reggie
themed art festival it's a lead to you
if you're into death metal you might
have a really dark festival we've no
light and it's case all completely
themed to make it really tailored to
people's tastes there is see the
dumpsters and porta potty section that
while not glamorous definitely essential
to the proper function what would the
festive we be without toilets dude you
need to get that stuff slide out right I
how many festivals did you uh expense to
the old studio in the Konami development
is she sitting just off camera here I
have not actually done that yet I think
I'd like to do for we're a freemium game
so we're trying to keep costs down I
think he's answered to me would be you
know very well what it is so yeah lyric
I might try it oh we'll see it's worth a
shot at least uh well it's it's free to
play but let's talk about you know folks
who either like want a little bit more
out of want to support you guys by
spending a little money on the game show
what what kind of options you have there
for that so currently the way that we're
monetizing it is we have a boost system
right so it's basically and we don't
want this to be some cynical cash grab
where we just constantly my bring you
for money because this was always about
making a great game genuinely sony came
into the free-to-play space to
experiment but absolutely do try and do
it better we don't want to be tarred
with the same brushes some of the you
know less so you know well you know
Facebook titles without getting into the
shoe store yeah and so yeah we wanted to
try and do this better and the idea with
this is that we have this or section of
boosts and you build you use them to
advance your time so everything in the
game you can just grind if you want
right there will be points within the
game where you may have to grind at some
time to get what you need and you will
pay for to pay the sorcerer bet that
time but it's still stuff that you can
achieve or acquiring we're not there's
enough this looking within the game that
you can't grind for we make we want to
be really sort of clear about that so
everyone can have everything in the game
if they put the effort in but we don't
want it again we don't want it to be
something where you
are playing it for four years and years
and not getting what you need out the
game we want to balance it and make it
fair well alright now the other side of
this right that's not not the player
side i guess the band side let's say
there's a i mean there are tons of bands
out there who are dying to get some
exposure totally how how do they get
their stuff into the game how do they
you know upload their music their their
art their you know their band glamour
shots show we're currently working on
the specifics but we have a landing page
on the jamendo website okay well we're
going to have a landing page if it's not
there it'll be on our site the idea is
you upload your your track for inclusion
then they'll be sort of a process of
evaluation you'll add your band art and
you put your bio in and is in the game
and yeah we want to make that sort of
route into the game really quick and
really you know convenient for people
what the idea is that the more music in
the game the more that is about people
the better yeah and I mean especially
when you know I mean the more music
that's in there just the more enrich the
experience is the more and the more
likelihood that someone's going to find
some musically legitimately enjoy
totally that and this is the thing that
we find quite interesting is what we've
been playing it when we put it into QA
there are you know there are trucks in
there that I now genuinely really like
me actually like them so there is that
you are actually discovering music and
that's there's something very compelling
about that idea and I won't want to go
out on a limb and say the gamification
of music because that might be a little
bit of a stretch too far well certainly
that's kind of our thinking we think why
not I know it instead of listening to
music passively you play a game with
music in you know you sort of your play
and you know a lot of people play games
and put on their own music tracks and so
having a diversity of discoverable music
there strikes me is a really neat way
you know not just the undie game design
challenge but also a way to engage with
the music scene and with with artists
and bands and musicians that is it has
not really been done in this way before
totally honest I mean this is only day
one right so day one will allow people
to get into the game
on that who knows if this takes off
people are really interested in it and
we see a lot of people using it we're
going to be got lots of things on the
horizon for bands specifically you know
there may be deals we could do with
marketing to get them competitions and
all of that stuff so it's all really
exciting sounds pretty ambitious Lee I'm
excited to see where you guys go whether
you gotta try without trying absolutely
that's big fest coming to the
PlayStation Vita we're looking around
Christmas on Christmas time all right
well best of luck to you guys in the
continuing all right Mitch Chris thanks
for coming on the stage and showing it
off